We would love to do a rapid fire,
get into many of our favorite movies that you were in,
and if you could share any fun facts about them,
we would be so delighted in something we call
"Behind The Scenes".
(audience applauding)
Okay, here's how it works,
we're going to show you a movie that you were in
and we would love for you to share a detail
and insider fly on the wall moment,
anything that comes to mind.
First up "St. Elmo's Fire".
Well, it was off set,
like what comes to me first is
I was renting a place out in Los Angeles
and my next door neighbor was Betty Davis.
And I never saw her until one night I had a few drinks
and I decided I'm going to go meet Betty Davis.
And I went and I knocked on her door
and then I panicked and I just ran home.
So I sort of,
and that was it.
I never met her.
Okay "Mannequin"
The first thing always jumps to my mind about "Mannequin"
is that I hated that motor,
I had to ride a motorcycle in the movie
and I couldn't ride it,
I would just get so tense when I do it,
like my shoulders would tense up so much
that I crashed early on
and they realized that no, he's not joking,
he can't ride the motorcycle
and so they had to just hook it up with some rig
every time I rode it
and so that I would be pulled along,
and have to like put a fan on me to blow my hair
and all this kind of stuff
because I was so incapable of riding my motorcycle.
Okay "Less Than Zero".
I never read the book.
My big secret from "Less Than Zero" is I never read it,
which we would all sit around
and they would talk about the book and I would be like,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
and I'm like, I have no idea what they're talking about.
But it was kind of good because the movie
had nothing to do with the book.
I don't think there was a single line
from the book in the movie,
but I did end up reading it decades later.
But yeah, I wasn't much of a reader back then.
Okay, last one "Weekend at Bernie's".
See the problem with telling stories
about Bernie is everything is on screen.
Anything you could think of, it wasn't stupid enough.
I remember it was like, let's staple,
let's say he has a toupee and staple his hair on him.
Like, okay, put a ball cap on him,
let's staple his head.
You know, there's a scene when we were doing Monopoly,
playing Monopoly,
I was playing Monopoly against dead Bernie
and it wasn't in the script I just had nothing to do
and I had been playing Monopoly at home the night before,
so I brought my Monopoly set to the work and I said,
let me play Bernie in Monopoly,
so we just had this Monopoly match,
and it turned out to be great.
You know, you can do anything to Bernie,
you could just drag him around,
we realized the more you abuse his body,
the funnier it's gonna be.
There is a folklore if you will,
that my grandfather, John Barrymore,
they took his body out of the morgue, his friends,
W.C Fields, Sadakichi Hartmann, John Decker, and Gene Fowler
and they partied with him and it's this infamous story
and they say, I have heard rumors
that it was like a molecule of inspiration
for "Weekend at Bernie's",
did you ever hear that?
That could well have been true,
but we did not have such a fine pedigree as that.
We were just a couple of fools
fooling around with this dead body, so no.
As fabulous as they all were,
they were total hedonists and party animals.
And they were totally a bunch of hooligans.
By the way, really quickly,
I didn't know this, is it true that you wore a wig
at the very end of "Pretty in Pink"
because you had shaved you head
for "Less Than Zero" already?
I was doing a play in New York and I shaved my head,
but I do have a wig on at the end of "Pretty in Pink",
'cause we reshot the ending and so,
when I go to Molly at the prom and tell her that I love her,
and I'm a terrible person and she's great,
that was all a reshoot.
They never die these movies
And they can't, they're such a part of our history.
(audience applauding)
Andrew McCarthy "Brat, An 80's Story"
is out now everywhere books are sold.
Thank you, Andrew.
(upbeat music)